Many organizations use a software change control board,
or SCCB to set priorities.
This is a group of people who look into the problem database
and take care of the handling of the problems.
Such a group typically consists of developers, testers, and managers.
What they do is the keep track of resolved and unresolved problems,
assign a priority to individual problems,
and then assign these problems to individual developers.
As you can see, a problem database is a very important tool
in the management of a product.
All the discussion on all the features eventually is stored in here.
You can even use it as a tool for requirements management.
When the project starts you enter a single problem in here,
which states the product is missing.
Then you add up more requirements and more requirements,
which eventually will have to be fulfilled.
A board like the SCCB then decides who should take care of
which issue and when.